the only thing harder than being the
world's top spy he is keeping the secret
I have to go on an important mission
I mean Erin from her kids Spy Kids for
all the time in the world yeah I saw it
you know why I do it for you guys the
movie stars Jessica Alba Jeremy Piven
Joel McHale and Ricky Gervais has a
little dog and some kids that are spies
deer war directed by Robert Rodriguez
who has the most interesting and strange
filmography as I was looking it up he's
directed like some really good movies
like he hasn't movies in cities in the
top I'm to be 250 Sharkboy and Lavagirl
and you know it I'm going to summer the
plot that's moving like two seconds of
the Spy Kids new spy kids okay there you
go there's new Spy Kids Jessica Alba's
the stepmom these guys turtle panic
hello children I am a spy this is a
prank this is the entire gimmick with
this movie aromascope little numbers
come up on the screen kind of like this
and you know it's a no look there's
number one well let me scratch number
one Oh what do you know it smells like
blueberries or something this is the
entire reason this movie was made this
right here where ever ever it gets
directed wrote compose the music for and
was a director of photography for this
movie so if there is anything to blame
it's him if I'll just take a dump right
now take the turd right now just go
across the wall like that that would be
more entertaining and more interesting
to look at and more fun and better
smelling
than some of the cells off his card then
everything about spike gets bored I
absolutely hated this movie I hit it so
much and you know when I reviewed this
Marcille there's a few random people who
apparently liked it who commented they
were like why why do you hate this movie
it's made for kids this is made for you
of course you're gonna hate it I know
that this stupid movie is made for
children okay but it insults children
this movie thinks that children are the
stupidest little kids are like OOP OOP
OOP OOP sometimes that's funny if
handled and done in the right way but I
remember when I was a kid I was still
able to recognize that certain movies
were better than the others like when I
went to see The Smurfs there was a kid
who as soon as it ended he like shot up
an estate newsletter came on let's go I
mean if you would have really liked the
movie and if it would have been like a
lion king like experience for him he
would have just been saying they're in
their credits like yay no you weren't
delete so I really want to hear any of
those comments because this is so bad
ah when the world needs saving this is
the spy kids division
the power where the kids napping is in
their hands
where are they really the special
effects are so terrible every single
fight scene is like enhanced and change
with with digital effects like
everyone's little punches are sped up
really fast the main villains movie is
the timekeeper he wants to stop time and
what I'll get it um I couldn't stand
this movie it was so syncing horrible I
hated it you know what else is really
dumb about this movie it's the fact that
it expects us to smell certain smells on
this aromascope card and it and it
smells like crap I mean it's literally
like a baby will poop or someone picks
their nose or something and you're like
scratch number six what do you know it
smells like crap yay I love that
experience there's entire scenes
completely directed and created off of
this stupid part like a kid goes in like
a little candy area grabs candy and just
eats it like a good ten seconds it's
also you can smell this candy and it
smells horrible
it's dominant doesn't work and the
entire every single smell just kind of
creates a hybrid stench of some kind
during one of the poop fart whatever
barf smells there was a kid up in the
theater like choking and coughing and
gagging cuz he smelled it what are you
singing with this crap I hate this movie
oh alright went behind the dresser now
I'm gonna have to look for you get the
action
get the adventure right cute goes in the
bag not on my phone there are a few
redeeming qualities to this film one of
them being Ricky Gervais is the dog it's
kind of silly and funny at times
although I honestly cannot really think
of a great Jessica Alba movie at all um
she's nice to look at other than that
this movie is an atrocity it's terrible
it's not as quite as bad as the Smurfs
even though I really hated that movie
too spikey it's all the time in the
world activated I love doing that I'm
gonna give spike it's for Adi - yes an F
would be my lowest grade since
everyone's asking and a plus that's my
eyes there you go everyone's asking that
but please just don't even see us we
don't take your kids to see this movie
it will lower their IQs it has no
respect for children it thinks they're
idiots
and it just it panders to like that low
this is all we can do and I don't know
why it's movies made please don't see it
if you liked this review subscribe to my
channel and get stuck my knives
Oh